CHANCE OF SURVIVOR.
IT LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING OUT OF
SCIENCE FICTION MOVIE.
THIS IS JOHNATHON HUNT.
>> IT IS REAL AND IT IS IT
FLYING AND WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
IT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE FLYING
VEHICLE THAT COULD SAVE AMERICAN
ON HIGHWAYS HERE AT HOME.
>> IT IS TO MAX MIS TIME YOU
NEED TO GET THE VICTIM EVACUATED
AND WITHIN MEDICAL ATTENTION IN
AN HOUR.
IT WAS BORN OUT OF THE 2006
ISRAEL HESBOLLAH FAR WHERE IT
TOOK FIVE HOURS TO EVACUATE
ISRAELIA SOLDIERS.
>> BECAUSE OF THE AIR FIRE AND
PHYSICAL LIMITATION OF THE
HELICOPTER ROTA R IT CANNOT
LAND.
>> IT IS TESTED IN ISRAEL WITH
BETWEEN SUPPORT FROM THE ISRAELI
MILITARY.
PRODUCTION IS PLANNED TO MOVE TO
THE UNITED STATES AND PILOTLESS
AND PILOTED MODELS TO BE
AMERICAN FOR MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN MERGE.
>> DISASTER RESPONSE.
AND NUCLEAR DECONTAMINATION AND
DIRTY BOMB IN THE CITY.
AND UP AGAINST THE WALL OF THE
BUILDING AND THIS AIRCRAFT CAN
DO THAT.
>> Reporter: THEY HOPE TO
PRODUCE COMORIENT IN 20
AUTHORITY 22.
THE COMPANY CALL ITS A WIN- WIN